oh that was something yeah beach city
drift
oh so this is an episode where Kevin is
back
did you remember who he was at the
beginning not as such I'm so glad they
brought him out cuz they're like talked
about for a while I'm just like please
say who this person is
oz Mike you want a guy that danced with
us Stefani I think is what uh heshes
called Gwen Stefani says yes this is um
and uh and made them uncomfortable the
first time so he drives up sir calls his
dad old man and stuff like that Stephen
gets angry and both Stephen Connie
really uh calls his dad cramp yes well
old man too because he says young man so
we're both right so when they finally
fuse together they get in this car race
and they're gonna race him down because
they want to show that they're over him
and better than him but by doing so
they're showing that they're obviously
not over him so and very valuable life
lessons in there yes and they make it to
the bottom which I've stated quite
clearly at the end yes I'm very
impressed how well they can drive a car
that see how their first time drive
already don't understand how they know
how to do I don't get any of that uh was
pearl giving them driver's ed on the
side what um then there was a weird
thing when it's like hopefully I'll be
explained later but like they sort of
entered this different dimension or
something and his face is there and then
they fuse apart um a it has to do with
fusing or something I don't know um and
then they're like happens you won but
it's cool we got a good view and our
first time driving we play your stupid
game even though they kind of do it's
good to get back in the car and they
keep going I think that I find the home
I don't know seems very muddled yeah a
little bit like I guess it if it just
ran I guess you're just raising arted so
I guess they're just racing mother
of it then like at the end it's like no
race we're racing against ourselves yeah
not this we do this is to prove some to
ourselves not to not to that dude like
it I guess is it always kind of proving
something to yourself in a sense kind of
yeah that you're better than that dude
yeah I guess um so um yeah a little
muddled and I'm not gonna lie you know
the first time we saw those two fuse was
like such a good kick ah such a good
episode I mean like it was really
fascinating and interesting I know
you're going like have a second time and
I'm like oh it's yeah okay sorry I feel
like that's the point though that they
came to like yeah I thought the same
thing I'm like really we're doing a
fusion episode for this but I think that
was the point when she's like they
literally practically said just we fused
for this mmm like really like this this
sacred weird super spiritual Power
Rangers act or whatever cuz this d-bag
like so I did kind of like that I I
don't know I know yeah like it's not bad
but it's it's just like okay like that
that happened you know um nice I'm a
little curious what that when they're
driving is sort of went to these stars
in the road was crumbling stuff unless
that's just how they see things you know
it could be like in their interpretive
thing I don't I just thought they were
going really fast and but the road was
crumbling behind it and they see like
his face in front of them and everything
and they come apart uh so I didn't get I
think there was a representation of them
coming apart like that's what I'm
wondering yeah um but guys it's
okay yeah I think II can't say too much
else about it um I that episode exists
yeah
this is not good not bad it's a very
middle of the road cuz I'm like a
Ronaldo episode at least I'm not filled
with complete loathing for the episode
time he was on screen Oh
even that even that few seconds I'm just
like I'm like I'm like expecting him to
say a funny line but it never comes out
there's like some good setups and then
like it never comes out I'm just like oh
yeah cuz you're Renauld
Oh ah that literally it is like trying
to put a cat in a bathtub I am just any
time he pops up on screen like I
literally claw his face I'm still
healing um so uh yeah hopefully next
episodes not for anyone although based
um but uh yeah we can probably just make
this a short one I don't know what else
to say like it is the there it is iris
racing probably the shortest one we've
ever done um we just really want to get
to the other ones because we're Elijah
it goes down and we'll see you when
Elijah goes down by racing